pierre guerlain bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors une
héroïne américaine pour le candidat
démocrate joe biden
il a appelé par ailleurs à ne pas se
précipiter pour la remplacer alors
pourquoi les démocrates crime d'un
remplacement rapide alors il faut savoir
qu'en 2016
barack obama avait proposé le nom d'un
juge pour la cour suprême et que le
leader républicain du sénat mitch
mcconnell avait refusé de présenter les
candidats d'obama en disant qu'ils
avaient avoir une élection et que donc
le président devrait choisir et là dans
une hypocrisie maximum le même qu'en 9
me précipiter un vote au sénat
remplacez groupe b d'acs et donc bader
ginsburg qui effectivement une femme
extraordinaire
non seulement parce qu'elle défend les
droits des femmes et l'égalité
hommes-femmes mais elle a aussi pris
position pour garder le contrôle des
états qui pratiquent à la discrimination
raciale dans le sud
donc c'est une femme qui est
extraordinaire parce que elle a toujours
lutté pour l'égalité entre tous et ce
qui se passe maintenant c'est que les
républicains au sénat veulent précipiter
son remplacement avant donc l'élection
du 3 novembre
et effectivement pourquoi politiquement
donald trump bon lui a salué aussi une
femme exceptionnelle 1 pour autant
pourquoi il a un père est nommé très
rapidement son successeur politiquement
alors lorsqu'il dit que c'est une femme
exceptionnelle on peut supposer que
c'est aussi très hypocrite parce qu'elle
représente
tout le contraire de ce que représente m
donc ils vendent ses mérites
une fois que elle est décédée mais il
veut faire élire un troisième une
troisième juge qui sera très
certainement dans le même moule que les
deux précédents c'est à dire ça mettra
en jeu les droits à l'avortement pour
pour commencer et pour tout ce qui
concerne l'égalité entre blancs et noirs
entre
personnes lgbt et autres les candidats
de john probablement seront très très à
droite et il a déjà eu la possibilité de
nommer deux juges et un secret qui est
énorme pour n'importe quel président
avec un troisième ça assurerait une
majorité ultraconservatrice de 6 à 3
c'est à dire que pendant peut-être
trente années puisque les juges qui l'a
nommé sont relativement jeune il y
aurait une cour suprême qui a joué un
rôle politique énorme aux états unis qui
serait le mot conservateur et peu
approprié qui sera hyper réactionnaire
parce que elle la juge elle-même avait
confié à ses dernières volontés à sa
petite fille je vais la cité mon voeu le
plus cher est de ne pas être remplacés
temps qu'un nouveau président n'aura pas
prêter serment elle traînait ce scénario
oui elle craignait ce scénario et lors
de l'élection de teintes elles avaient
de façon peu habituel pour les juges la
cour suprême pris position contre le
candidat john parce que boyet venir le
candidat du chaos est effectivement à
quelques semaines près son décès va
peut-être donner une possibilité aux
républicains il est passé n'est pas sûr
que tous les républicains vont suivre
mais c'est une situation hyper critiques
non seulement pour le droit des femmes
mais quand on dit le droit des femmes
c'est une féministe égalitariste et là
par exemple défendu à boeufs qui voulait
avoir les mêmes droits pour la garde de
ses enfants que les droits accordés aux
femmes est donc absolument parfaite pour
l'égalité entre tous les citoyens et on
sait très bien que jobs veut déportés la
cour suprême vers une droite extrême et
dure contre les femmes et aussi contre
l'égalité entre les groupes raciaux
contre l'égalité dans la société
donc c'est effectivement un enjeu très
crucial pour conclure en quelques mots
on sait que les républicains sont
majoritaires au sénat
pour autant
vous faisiez comprendre tout à l'heure
que ce n'était pas sûr que le sénat
avalise le choix de donald trump
pourquoi alors il ya trois ou quatre
personnes dont l'élection des
républicains et républicaine susan
collins qui ont fait doit faire face à
des déchets challenger important qu'ils
ne vont pas forcément soutenir la
démarche
certains d'entre eux ont dit dans le
passé qu'il ne le ferait pas mais ils
n'y peuvent changer d'opinion
donc là il ya une question de timing
d'une part et une question de
positionnement des républicains qui ne
sont pas forcément en accord avec le
boul deux aires de mccaw non merci
beaucoup pierre guerlain l'avoir partagé
votre analyse je rappelle que vous êtes
professeur de civilisation américaine à
paris 10